[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
when we talk about what yeah we go there
do I have to tell you something okay
so I've been saving this story but I
forgot it
last week I totally forgot about it but
I tweeted about this [ __ ] right so like
when I was on my way to Madonna's
headquarters I was I was on this
aeroplane United but it's not their
fault
okay first experience of a bat [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy person I've never it was
it was crazy like I was like I don't
know what the [ __ ] was gonna happen was
she gonna tell you how long into the
fight she'd go crazy I gotta give you
how I realize she was crazy
that's why okay okay alright so this is
how the story goes three seats on my
side okay I'm on the aisle alright so
the so the way that the airplane is
three seats there three she's there all
the way down up and down alright where
she is sitting is behind me but like
across across okay not it so let me so
let me explain who's next to me older
white couple in their 50s yeah
on the right of me like like a white mom
in her fifties of she has a teenage son
and then a young black dude in his 20s
okay right behind them nerdy white guy
college student yeah empty chair and
then crazy lady Oh crazy lady yeah she
was like African or something she had an
accent
and then um or she I forgot what country
she's fun but she's this this is very
important to the story
I forgot remember it but then anyways on
this side of the aisle behind me big
black dude maybe in his 30s maybe I
don't know bright black don't crack
I don't know I'm like he's sick
something he's huge when I go back his
[ __ ] knees touching my elbow he's big
yeah
to the left behind me - lesbian white
ladies but not unconfirmed I just
assumed 20 right there in the back
alright so this is what happens we take
we take off okay I [ __ ] sleep you
know I'm [ __ ] sleeping because it
feels [ __ ] Bob to sleep on the
airplane
we've all asleep but it's not the best I
got to be in a bed - is the best because
even when I'm not tired and I drank a
lot of coffee when I'm lifting off on my
own something happened those people yeah
immediately my positive immediately -
but it's very uncommon that I wake up
like what the [ __ ] was that
so we take off and then I wake up and
this [ __ ] is crying she's like like
that like like somebody died like it
sounds like somebody died everyone's
like we're like looking over
like [ __ ] loud right and I'm like she
looks like anything yeah she looks like
um kind of all right she's like a chunky
chunky black girl like well she's
actually fat okay yeah and then uh her
hair tied back hair tight back yeah it
didn't you know like like in her 30s
maybe where I forgot what she was
wearing
that she did she look relatively normal
yes you would never expect he's never
know in it she looked she looked good
like clean she looked she doesn't look
like a bum or anything like that just
just normally dressed right
whatever you yeah yeah yeah and it's so
like um [ __ ] crying it was like what
the [ __ ] just happened right and in the
the lady in front of her you know she
turns around she's like honey I fly all
the time if this is nothing it's just a
little turbulence don't worry about it
you know she'll be okay and so I was
like okay so she thinks it's turbulence
and then she just keeps crying and
everyone's just like oh just let her
[ __ ] be and then as soon as she got
comforted she stops and she looks over
to the guy next to her and she goes and
they start flirting she starts flirting
with them out of nowhere like oh so uh
how many times have you been in Chicago
yeah loud Oh out of nowhere with an
African accent yeah I love the view PD
Chicago yeah like so she has so her
accent is slight it's not it but it does
sound like that but very slight like
don't you come over yeah yeah yeah and
then um most both are talking right you
know it's getting kind of weird all of a
sudden she goes yeah I'm just so sad
because there's this dead baby every
time I see him he follows me everywhere
everywhere I see him he doesn't leave me
alone as he walked and then everyone's
just like listening to this [ __ ] like
holy what oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did she
just say she sees his dead baby
everywhere that's creepy [ __ ] that
and instead this guy I mean he was a he
was up he was the man because like you
could totally tell he was uncomfortable
but he was just taking it and it I don't
know where she goes so do you like um
[ __ ] I forgot what country but do you
like this African country food and he's
like oh I never tried it right because
I'll make it for you
to my house you know what I'm gonna have
a housewarming party why don't you put
your number in my phone I'll call you
and I'll invite you you can sleep in my
on my couch
we could have it'll be fun so she forces
him to put his number in there and he
did it he I mean he was being a trooper
man I think like she's just crazy only
puts a month and immediately she was pop
I thought she was she was like claiming
him as her like man she would she would
she got out of her [ __ ] chair she
would rub her nose on him all that yeah
like she would come up to her it to his
face and then like rob try to kiss him
mo kiss yeah yeah and he's just like
giggling and like kind of comfortable
like that nerdy guy no no he was the big
black dude behind me yeah yeah so
there's a nerdy college student kid next
door where this is happening
I see I'm curing everything and I'm
listening leacy somebody go over do this
to somebody she's doing that [ __ ] and
then you know I think the flight
attendant like man please sit down and
she was okay so she gets back down she
puts her thing on and then she's she's
talking loud [ __ ] loud like she's
like talking to people this and that and
then um at one point I think people were
getting kind of annoyed so the other
black guy in front of her at the edge by
the by the window he turned around and
he was like he was like like I guess
trying to tell would be quiet he was
like you know like it's like can you can
you keep it down a little bit and then
she immediately got like mad she was
furious at him and then cuz I think he
was just talking for everybody like hey
you could talk but like he's your voice
low you know and she goes you want me to
be quiet you want me to shut up why why
do you want me to shut up like she
started treating him as if she was his
life he was his he was her ex-husband
like they were starting to argue and
then he was just like nah like I just
want the whole time he's just like I
just want you to be quiet like that and
I'm like damn dude these guys are
[ __ ] brave and then she turns around
and she turns around and she told the
other black guy like do you think I have
to be quiet am i bothering you am i
bothering you and then he's just like
look like I don't know what to say and
then the two lesbian girls they're like
unconfirmed unconfirmed
might be sisters I just thought oh my
god if they were cuddly okay but sisters
cuddle too but if they had short pixie
cuts so they kind of babies Inc of
lesbians were they making out though no
they were making out but were they
feeling each other that's the question
and they turned around and they were
like they're like ma'am just calm down
like it's okay like you could talk just
keep your voice down that's all we're
asking for it goes what and she [ __ ]
turns around and out of nowhere she goes
to the the nerd the white kid and she
goes do you think what do you think do
you think I should shut up
what do you think and then he's like
knob just I'm just I don't I don't know
man I don't know I like Black Panther
was a great he's like he's on his head
yeah whatever
yeah he's like he's like I don't know
he's like I don't know is it because I'm
black
are you afraid to tell me because I'm
black and she was you afraid of me huh
and then he's like no no he's like I
don't care it's like cuz you crazy and
then he stopped responding because he
just wanted to ignore her but he was
scared and then I didn't hear - yeah and
then the next thing she does is she
grabs his hand and she goes touch my
skin are you afraid of my skin because I
am black
yeah the nerdy guy said yeah she grabbed
his hand and she was trying to make her
touch I'm jealous are you afraid to
touch my skin oh no and it was like wow
there's just getting [ __ ] crazy right
exactly so then now I look over and then
the the white couple next to me they're
freaking out and the whole time they're
going being ding ding ding ding trying
to get the [ __ ] flight attendant to
come no one's filming this no it just
happened so fast there no and the
flenders they're not coming no one knew
what the [ __ ] to do because like it was
so it happened really fast and it was
like up and down and up and down this is
what we're talking about yeah people
think that they know what they're gonna
do in the hot in an intense situation
but when it happens you don't your mind
goes blank yeah
yeah violent it just escalated really
quick but it was just it was weird right
it's like she's not really hurting
anyone and being violent but she's just
being distracted
yeah disruptive and and awkward so it
didn't it didn't get there yet right but
I was like okay this might be [ __ ]
crazy like I don't know what's gonna
happen so I just like took off my
[ __ ] my seat belt right you tied your
shoes and [ __ ] my headphones on yeah I
took that cuz I told it out of order
because what happened was when the two
ladies started yelling back at her to
distract her away from [ __ ] with the
kid she went even crazier toward them
and then she got up like this and that's
why I was like oh [ __ ]
I better you know jump in because the
guy would have she was she was yelling
over the guy like this so then he
wouldn't have been able to move or
whatever you know and then if I got a
new toy he's sick something just go
black he was like he was like this crazy
don't care about sighs yeah but it's all
like whoa I'm not gonna beat her but at
least if I get up I could probably be in
a middle you know yeah look I mean she
wasn't scary like she was just crazy I
know for some reason I know I know I
know this sounds wrong but when I see a
crazy person I immediately think they're
gonna bite me in the evades
I mean that that's true but or not aids
per se but some kind of Disney she just
wasn't happy she just wasn't like they
might have the head seats they have to
see I mean the hippies you know I was
like the worst that she's cute I know
heavy seas yeah I mean the worst that
she could she could have probably done
was like swing but it was so close
quarter that it wouldn't no I don't
think it would have been okay so anyways
that's what that was what was on my mind
we were like where the [ __ ] is a flight
attendant right and then she's like the
girls are like sit back down there
yelling I'm just like fog this is crazy
so she's over here
sitting on on the armrest like this and
she's yelling at them and she's getting
closer and then they're like the flight
attendants coming and she looks up and
she's like oh okay and then she's like
putting her seatbelt on and then trying
to act like a good kid so she actually
get scared of the flight attendants it
that's crazy
it was so [ __ ] weird and it reminded
me of a kid where it's like the teachers
coming and that neither angel asked it
was that crazy then because she knows
right from wrong yeah that's weird
that's pretty creepy it is [ __ ] crazy
though it's so crazy because okay so
this is what happened the reason why the
flight attendants were taking so long is
because they were pushing that cart
because it was right at that drink time
no they were bringing that thing up
right and as soon as they passed a
section to ask us what was going on they
turned around and looked at the two
white couple and under like is there
something wrong the the lady grabs like
the box full of all the sugars and stuff
and knocks it over and in the flight
attendants were like what are you doing
why did you do that because they don't
know what just happened yeah and then
she's like oh I'm so sorry and she tries
to like start cleaning up everything and
everyone was like it's a distract from
the other situation so they wouldn't
tell on her no no she just went bowling
like that and they're like why did you
do that and she goes oh I'm so sorry and
then she was like just starting to help
everyone like grab the sugar packets and
it's like what oh yeah and by the way
every time someone walked by her to go
to the bathroom she would bump them and
be like I'm sorry and then try to give
them hugs and all this [ __ ] yeah yeah so
there's a lot of that kind of [ __ ] that
I would act out for her yeah and I'm
only shortening this but there were
multiple times that she cried in between
all of that but what did the flight
attendants do at the end of the day okay
so basically they told her she has to
like calm down right and then another
guy came and then he was like excuse me
ma'am it was it was like a gay old man
those guys are like the best flight
attendants by the way because they're
like strong mothers yeah and then he's
all like excuse me ma'am if you if you
if you get up and disturb this flight
one more time you're gonna be in deep
trouble like like something
the lines of that right and she's like
okay I just go to sleep I would go to
sleep I will not say anything and then
she uh so then this is what she does she
gets a blanket and puts it over her head
right and she's [ __ ] with their phone
and I'm like thank god she's she's gonna
be quiet so I reality out like thirty
minutes of quiet and then I start
hearing noise on her phone and I'm just
like [ __ ] I can't I can't not listen to
it what is this and she's laughing at
she's like she's laughing right and
she's laughing and she's like
interacting with her phone and it was
herself talking to herself about her
best friend being this [ __ ] [ __ ] in
a liar but it was her best her best
friend is herself one strike he
demonstrate like have a conversation
between the phone but it was like it was
she was like gossiping with herself
about herself was it that FaceTime or
was a pre-recording I couldn't see
that's to me pre-recording she can face
there's a pre-recording of hash numbers
yes okay so she videoed herself talking
about herself
can you believe this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
so stupid or like something like that
cuz he was talking to herself he was my
best friend
oh because like she was having the
conversation with herself it was like
that's what you that's what she thought
oh yeah you know and then she's like
she's doing both of the voices oh yes
she's basically gossiping oh and she's
watching herself gossip about herself or
whatever and she's laughing Wow
yeah I'm so curious and it everyone else
was just like okay she's she's laughing
she's having a good time
[ __ ] this is annoying but let her be
just [ __ ] let her be she's happy now
it's better than her [ __ ] crying yeah
yeah it didn't like yeah during all of
this like don't just be moments where
she just burst into like tears she
doesn't say anything
no it's like hard to it's like it's like
funeral crying so what happened after
like the plane landed well so at the
very end she did their thing that was
like toward the end right like she put
the blanket over her head she would you
know knock out she'll be quiet
she at least controlled herself we land
and as soon as we landed I think she
felt bad about the disruption so she got
up first and then she started opening up
the the things and pulling down the
[ __ ] suitcases for everybody and
everyone's like no no no no stop stop we
got it we got it and she insists she
grabs that [ __ ] down and [ __ ] serve
people and then like so she would she
would repeatedly do things like this
where she would feel bad and she was
[ __ ] [ __ ] up she's if she likes to go
yes she liked to go the extra mile to
like to like help you yeah don't worry I
suck everybody's the kid yeah no and
she's like hugging people like I'm sorry
and everyone's just kinda like okay got
a guy go I gotta go
it was [ __ ] nuts but I know if she
told the guy that she's been flirting
with right she's all like so uh what are
you gonna do and he goes I don't know
like you know just forget come home to
my wife go home like I just I don't know
I'm not I don't know I'm gonna go like
he doesn't know what to answer he goes
and then she goes you don't have to lie
to me if you don't want to be with me oh
my god was just yeah they she's like
guess what I'm pregnant are you gonna
leave me oh it was torn out of it guess
what it is yours this tab is your so
they're our whole relationship was like
it was like all by myself
that'd be so crazy I was four five hour
flight it was crazy yeah I mean there's
one there's even one time oh yeah I
missed this part where when when the the
flight attendants came and then pulled
up the cart she was like oh yeah I'm
going to the bathroom I was getting up
because I had to go the bathroom cuz
they're telling it or staying or see she
goes to the bathroom
and that's when everyone got a chance to
talk to a flat ends like this is what's
happening like we don't know if she's
intoxicated or she's just having a
breakdown or what we don't know like but
but she needs to be controlled and then
while we're saying this in the bathroom
she goes oh I mean we're like see that's
what's happening yeah [ __ ] it was just
nuts they should have brought like a
thing to seal the bathroom doors keepers
I know an exorcism is all she needs dude
dude be-because one little extras in
that baby ghost is [ __ ] her up dude
baby it was hella anoying though because
you can't escape yeah yeah if you want
like especially cuz I was reading a book
and I'm like I'm like reading I'm like
it's a good book it's called the go
Giver
and I'm like I'm like mmm I had to give
I did I have to be nice and give I'm
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
crazy dude I wonder who's gonna pick her
up from the airport
right how did she get home I didn't I
did follow us yeah oh yeah
it's good you're getting a little bit a
little bit because I just wanted to see
what she was gonna do so I went to the
bathroom and I saw her with all of her
stuff on the floor she was calling
random people and I was just kind of
like mmm what's going on is associated
with right how'd you afford the plane
ticket like who bought your ticket all
this [ __ ] right so anyway she puts all
her stuff on the ground and then she
goes up to this guy this unsuspecting
guy he doesn't even know [ __ ] and she
strikes up a conversation and then I'm
like oh you don't even know what the
[ __ ] what's going on to you yeah but
this was still in the airport okay and
then during that it was it was more like
she's appearing normal right now dude
but you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
in for yeah yeah and then after that I
was just I lost interest because it was
just too normal
oh geez I walk that way well it might
erupt you know but yeah she was just she
was she's she's very friendly it does
seem like she's just a powerful
personality I just have to see who
picked her up that's what yeah I want to
see who she's associated what is her
home look like yeah exact cause if she
came in
there's my giraffe and then she gets up
I want to see what you know like who the
[ __ ] was gone right because what she
comes in this it's like a whole family
comes pick her up and they're all the
same imagine they're all the same yeah
this grammar the vanities what you drive
a hover subject is nuts do you know oh
man she's a little Asian family Oh
that'd be crazy dude hurry up get inside
the car fluid Cantonese I know I'm gonna
be amazing as an African accent yeah it
was it was just nuts man that's for her
what up right before we cut I gotta see
what country it is cuz I need I need I
need I need to put that into context
real quick man it's [ __ ] crazy I have
a canyon canyon canyon there we go
Canyon all right that's it now we could
cut
[Music]